we're only a month into 2016 and already
the best new story of the years happened
for me at least a new paper mario game
for the Wii U is rumored to be announced
later this year I'm Kate and this is
your gamespot news update a new entry in
the paper mario series is apparently
being developed by intelligent systems
and will be released on the Wii U
according to reports Liam Robertson and
Emily Rodgers both of whom are
contributors to Nintendo life and have a
track record of correctly reporting
unannounced in Tendo projects have said
the game will be announced later this
year the information is based on five
different sources though these sources
were unnamed and it's not clear whether
they are from within Nintendo the game
is reportedly currently being localized
and tested which could mean that it will
be announced fairly soon and may even be
released relatively quickly after its
announcement should the report turn out
to be true Nintendo has not yet
officially confirmed that a paper mario
game is in development for Wii U but we
have contacted them for a comment are
you a huge paper mario fan do you like
me think that the series has been going
downhill since the best game of all time
Paper Mario in the thousand-year door
and thank you let me know in the
comments or come and find me on Twitter
I'm at how not to draw thanks for
watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot